ils sont onze d'agir à avoir travaillé
pendant un an à la sécurisation du site
du lazaret numéro deux dans le cadre
d'un atelier chantier d'insertion ces
hommes et ces femmes en situation
sociale fragile ont pu apprendre des
techniques de restauration bien
spécifiques on a ici 11 personnes qui
sont dans ce chantier d'insertion qui
ont eu 200 heures de formation avec
l'association cham encadrés par des
architectes du patrimoine et qui
apprennent aussi l'histoire et
apprennent à connaître si
l'environnement naturel le patrimoine
naturel et apprennent aussi à comprendre
et à connaître l'histoire de la réunion
l'histoire du lazaret avec plus de 200
heures de formation délivrée par le
chantier historique architecture
médiévale ces stagiaires valorise des
connaissances tout en préservant un
patrimoine historique fragile un double
objectif qui mêle culture et insertion
professionnelle ou un pays modèle en
ferraille accord de paix
avec le modèle en ferraille d'après
l'encadrement des fenêtres et la porte
pas de le monter les chars istres
patrimoine départemental les sites du
lazaret 1 et 2 font l'objet d'une
politique ambitieuse de préservation et
de valorisation
une valorisation qui passe également par
la connaissance avec la réédition de
l'ouvragé le catalogue du lazaret
[Musique]